today the big news will smith's academy
fate is sealed
[Music]
will smith just smack out of me
will smith is banned from attending an
oscar ceremony for the next 10 years
that was the academy's decision after
meeting on zoom for nearly three hours
this morning will is still apparently
eligible for future nominations but in
an open letter the academy called out
his behavior in the first sentence
describing his conduct as unacceptable
and harmful will responded i accept and
respect the academy's decision the
64-member board also praised chris rock
for quote his composure under
extraordinary circumstances
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television and the academy apologized
for its handling of the incident writing
during our telecast we did not
adequately address the situation in the
room for this we are sorry all along it
was unlikely that the academy was going
to revoke will's oscar insiders point
out the academy has not revoked oscar
wins for even the most disgraced winners
like harvey weinstein and roman polanski
who were accused of sexual assault we're
not going to take that oscar from him
academy board member whoopi goldberg who
generally has fridays off on the view
did not appear on today's live show she
was presumably on the academy zoom other
a-listers on the board include laura
dern rita wilson ava duvernay and steven
spielberg
today's board meeting wasn't the only
drama for will and jada i would say
don't just start filming me
without asking me
a resurfaced video of the couple talking
about their marriage is going viral i'm
still dealing with foolishness don't no
i know she yeah because she could daunt
us
jada was discussing an upcoming red
table talk episode in 2019 when she
captured this tense moment would you say
that she helped us heal the hurts that
we caused between one another my social
media presence is my bread and butter
okay so you can't just use me for social
media and not
you know don't just start bro i'm
standing in my house
don't just start rolling
[Music]